did you know that the European Union has
a total budget of around 140 billion
euros each year it's a lot of money but
on the other hand it represents only
around 1% of the union's wealth and this
budget goes to improving our everyday
life but now
it serves to stimulate the economy and
create jobs to modernize agriculture to
preserve and manage our natural
resources to fight against terrorism
organized crime and illegal immigration
to promote and protect our cultural
heritage but also to help the
development of countries outside the
Union or on a one-off basis in case of a
natural disaster and contrary to popular
belief the union's expenditure
represents only six percent of the total
budget
at every stage the budget is decided
democratically the European Commission
draws up the draft budget and submits it
to the ministers of the EU states within
the council and to the elected
representatives within the European
Parliament not everything is decided in
Brussels most of the projects financed
are chosen and managed by the Member
States where problems arise the European
Commission intervenes and can impose
Corrections
despite its complexity the process is
completely transparent
the accounts of the European Union are
published every year and the whole
budget is controlled by the European
Court of Auditors the Commission alone
is responsible for its management before
the European Parliament which has the
power to sanction it in case of
shortcomings moreover each citizen has
the possibility of checking the
beneficiaries of the EU budget in each
country on the web since it's your right
to ask questions and our duty to answer
them